foreign
[Music]
good afternoon everyone all right
um so welcome this is you do it yourself
versus manage it's a little short on the
slide but we had to fit it on there so
just to introduce ourselves really
quickly I am Kyle Benson I am Benji Soto
I'm a product manager in Google Cloud I
do data visualizations and AI yep I also
worked with the the cloud up you know
within the cloud operations Suite
um
through what we're going to be covering
today
um I'll just call out so originally we
depending on when you may have signed up
for this session we're going to have
someone from Wayfair join us
unfortunately Zubin had to cancel I just
wasn't able to make it but uh so we'll
quickly talk about sort of what they
achieved and if you're interested
they're also you know Wayfarer is in a
couple of other locations throughout the
uh the sessions this week so we're happy
to answer any questions about them or
you know maybe put you in touch with
them just based off of what your
interests are
so other than that we're going to be
talking you know a little bit about some
of the aspects people evaluate when
they're looking at you know DIY versus
manage the offerings specifically in the
reservability space I mean we so we work
within Cloud operation suite and so at a
high level we spend a lot of time
talking to customers about that
um but we want to make sure you know we
this is our sort of area of expertise
and so when we talk about that a lot of
the lessons learned that we've seen will
be focused on them so we'll cover a
couple of things in sort of areas I
think are
I'd say area of importance maybe not
necessarily to everyone but like when we
think about sort of uh how people
approach stuff and today how a lot of
businesses think about this it may not
always line up with what I would suggest
so just as quickly talk about Wayfarer
so as I mentioned Wayfarer is one of our
customers of the Year this year that was
a result of the work that they did with
us and we had um you know a pretty great
experience working with them they've
been great partners for us but one of
the big things for them is they came
from a um an open source offering where
ultimately they decided it was a little
bit easier to
to migrate to the cloud operations suite
and that originally started with Cloud
logging and they used both our logging
and metrics sort of used to to handle
this stuff but ultimately a really
positive experience for them they had 25
Opex savings on what they did moving
away from a manage sorry an open source
pipeline so a really great story a
really great experience for them and
we're really happy that they were able
to
speak more broadly about it although
like I said Zubin couldn't be here today
and so I did want to sort of highlight
in his own words what that really meant
and for them this really started with a
you know an elastic open source based
pipeline where they migrated really with
a heavy focus on you know their log base
volume uh that turned into using that
for log base metrics and using our
visualization tools and then also is now
in the process of evaluating our managed
service for Prometheus to sort of drive
that home
so
when we talk about what matters I think
you know at the end of the day what
you're really taught talking about when
you talk about DIY versus managed
service is that's the wrong button
there it is is build versus buyer right
these have existed for a long time I
think as long as long as there's been
software and even before software the
idea of build versus buys has always
been you know sort of the first place
engineering team start when they're
thinking about what they're working on
and so
really at the end of the day here is
like you know if you the thing I'll say
that's most important if you don't think
about this day in and day out or if you
don't
talk about it with your teams the the
most important thing I'll say is just
thinking about what's your mission and
why it matters and there's real
implications for that right prior to
coming to Google I was at red hat for
nine years and I was there at a point
where
um you know I think Red Hat fairly well
known but if not open source based
software company you know primarily or
originally focused on Linux offerings
and now very heavily focused in the
container space but
when when I was there we were growing a
lot and uh we used an open source mail
server and we used does anyone anyone
ever use etherpad
anyone familiar with that no okay ether
okay one one can so ether pad was sort
of an open source online uh
collaboration tool for document writing
uh so ultimately as we started to grow I
was when I joined there was like 4 000
people at that company we ultimately
outgrew
uh just some of the open source tooling
there was too much for us to maintain
and scale and for red hat that was sort
of an internal dilemma right red hat
really truly believed in open source and
I think one of the reasons I came to
Google is I think we also believe in
that commitment to open source but it
wasn't critical to our day-to-day
business and so ultimately we had to
make the decision uh to to move off of
ether pad and a really simple mail
server
um they actually ended up adopting
Google workspace right which is a happy
story because I can use them as a you
know sort of a quote here right but uh
it worked out really well for them it
worked out really well for us and it
really it reduced the amount of friction
we had while collaborating
yeah so what I'd like to do real quick
is run through an e-commerce example so
what's important for an e-commerce shop
any anyone
you want to sell products you want to
add to cart you want to check out
that is how you run the business to get
there you might invest in that product
catalog you might invest into
relationships with suppliers on Shore or
offshore negotiating with those
suppliers buying those products when you
buy those products how do you get those
products from International markets or
supplier zones to last mile delivery
with that customer and to do all of that
you might be using email you might be
collaborating with different employees
and you might be investing into a search
algorithm to make these products
discoverable on your storefront
well with the world of Google Cloud much
of that is already available for you you
can buy email from the cloud you can buy
collaboration tools so your employees
can collaborate you can leverage search
algorithms from the Google Cloud using
your data sets
and what that allows you to do is really
focus on what really matters which are
your competitive differentiators
that way you're not focusing on all
these other
non-differentiators so if you think
about building these products to build
direction does feel the most creative
because you get to express yourself and
who doesn't love building Tech products
right we all do right but in many cases
you should really think twice and really
consider should you actually buy it
instead
Kyle's going to talk a little bit more
about how there are many costs that come
with build versus Buy
yeah I think like I mean the the the
sort of big one that glares at me a lot
of the time when I when we talk to
customers when we meet them you know on
a day-to-day weekly basis whatever it is
is always this one an opportunity cost
and I think like show of hands who's
familiar with the word opportunity costs
or the phrase opportunity cost Okay cool
so actually I'll say like uh when I just
did in preparing for this talk
um you know there's a Pew research
article that said something like you
know half of people surveyed new at
opportunity costs men but opportunity
cost is at a high level the decision to
do something based off of
um you know sort of like what are you
missing as a result of not doing
something else right so if you don't
study for a test and you go to a movie
instead you know what's the opportunity
cost what is that ultimately the impact
of that on you
um and so when we talk about opportunity
cost in you know sort of Enterprise
spaces you know there are lots of teams
that handle this really well if you work
in a large organization maybe your
procurement team handles this for you uh
if they do you know maybe they're model
are really great you know if if not
maybe something that you need to start
taking on within your own engineering
org is really more focused on how do you
assess that and I'll say like you know
at a high level if you're using if
you're in a large organization your
procurement team might have a strong
understanding of some different models
there like one of the more popular ones
is a Monte Carlo model and that helps
you sort of assess all the different
factors and sort of all the different
risks as a part of what you're doing if
you're a smaller organization I just
recommend this book how to measure
anything we use this a lot within our
door research right so if you've ever
heard of Dora or any of the stuff we
talk about there in terms of like how do
we achieve velocity how do people or
teams that perform accidentally actually
you know operate this is a book
recommended by one of the original
researchers from that team so I really
encourage you like if you're not
familiar with it if it's sort of new to
you in terms of how you represent your
product team and what you're
representing in your org having some
baseline of how to measure and
understanding what your opportunity cost
I think is going to be really important
in most of these conversations
the second one you start to think about
especially within the observability
space is outage cost and this is sort of
a fun thing to maybe poke at but like
you know if I think you know Gartner a
few years ago estimated that you know
per minute it was 5600 USD for an outage
and the thing that we always sort of
come back to is you know if if you have
an outage or your observability platform
has an outage like what you know which
one is it right how do you know that
your business is not failing if you
can't uh actually visualize what's going
on so we see this a lot and in fact you
know I see this a lot specifically on
the metric side when we talk about or we
talk with customers using
um
uh you know like sort of Open Source
Prometheus where they just have they
don't have the ability to visualize
either on a regular basis they don't
have the uh the retention periods that
they need for the metrics it's one of a
couple of things like that but we really
see this pretty commonly
so an average cost really matters I will
say you know that doesn't mean you can't
ever have outages there's always going
to be some and there's you know there's
a level of acceptability there if you're
not familiar with outage and sort of
like how to calculate your outages
correctly I'd really recommend checking
out the SRE book which has a great guide
to implementing slos
and sort of deciding what's important to
you right like 100 availability is
almost never the answer uh you know I
think when you really think about it
most people are at you know four nines
uh 999.99
I've seen a couple of people ask for a
99 you know
99.995 and that's really pushing it
right like that's what is that I think
uh uh if I'm not I'm not going to do the
math right but I think it's like eight
minutes a month something like that so
you know like there there's there's
always going to be outages 100 is never
really going to be the answer but
there's things you can do to sort of
improve that and sort of figure out how
you measure that so
I'm going to go into a little bit more
on the SRE stuff only because if you
sorry SRE if you've never heard that
term a set reliability engineering I'll
use SRE going forward but SRE is a
methodology used at Google it's used
elsewhere too so um you know if you've
never heard of that there's lots of
stuff here you can consume to sort of
get more familiar with it but one of the
big factors in SRE is focusing on
reducing toil
and so when we talk about toil
um you know I I my first job my first
sort of real job was I was a Linux
administrator right so you know maybe
that's someone's role here but for me
this this Always Rings home very true I
also worked a lot in automation
especially when I was in red hat so when
I think about toil I really have like
very strong visual feelings on this way
I can almost taste the amount of stress
you know but so when we think about this
you know there's a couple of things like
you know what is toil well it's you know
non-tactical so it's almost always a
reactive posture to something
it is
lacking enduring value and so the
lacking enduring value is that if you do
this and there's a high likelihood
you're going to do it again right and
there's no opportunity for you to solve
or improve upon that basis that would be
lacking enduring value and then grows at
least as fast as its source right and
the idea there is like if you as a
business have a lot of Toil and you are
continuously growing your toil is going
to grow right it's going to grow with
commensurately with your business and
when you start to think about
how teams work how teams manage or how
teams are managed like that's a really
important factor to sort of think about
like this is our practical experience
working at Google that's where this book
came from but it's not only within
Google right I think most people sort of
understand this at a high level
uh productivity right so there's the
reason I bring this up is like at its
most basic you want your team to be
happy you want the people inside your
organization to be happy but there's
like if you're going to put this to a
spreadsheet there is a human cost to it
right and so I would encourage you to
check out the eliminating toils section
of the book but what does it cause right
it causes confusion and it causes
attrition right so if you have people
who are constantly cycling in and out of
your organization that's definitely
going to lead to confusion and
ultimately will lead to a less valuable
product for you or your end users and I
don't think that can be understated
does anyone anyone remember Dexter's Lab
all right cool all right I got a couple
people this is this is my idea of toil
this is the best best example that I
could find uh in the original show when
I was like as a kid he's super happy to
be doing this and then very quickly it
turns into just the monotonous day in
day out thing and that's what it feels
like when you're totaling away at
something right I always like that word
because it's sort of uh it just sounds
painful I don't know so when you think
about this there's a couple of things to
factor in and this is something we see a
lot of a lot of the time especially when
we start talking about open source
software is
um
you know the idea of human cost and the
idea there is like well if I'm going to
stand on my own you know again I'll lean
back on Prometheus if I stand up my own
Prometheus stack like how much time am I
going to have my team focused on this
um I would say it's almost it's almost
always uh an underestimation for people
when we meet them right but that's why
they're meeting with us so there's a
there's a little bit of bias there but
ultimately this is something that really
affects most teams and as you start to
grow especially in a tool like
Prometheus or other spaces not only does
the capacity come up higher on your your
actual Computer Resources but it also
increases your in terms of your your
individual status uh or your human
status as you're saying
foreign
I like this slide I like this sort of
definition because uh we used to always
say this and I'll come to the quote in a
second
um but when we talk about open source
software there is a
that idea that open source software is
free open source software is free right
I mean that's the sort of statement
um and there's obviously always a cost
behind that and I think a lot of people
get into that with us but this I like
this slide because the word Gratis is
you know I think it's I guess I should
say it's Latin I shouldn't say that with
certainty
but Gratis focuses on the idea that it
comes without a cost and Libre is like
Freedom right Liberty and so both of
those things mean free especially in the
English language like it's a very you
know it's not a clear distinction when
we say open source software is without a
cost I would say that's not true it's
this one right we're talking about
Liberty you have the liberty and the
freedom to do what you want with them
um and that's like maybe like an
esoteric pitch on it but I'll say like
generally We Believe open source
software is important if you look at
this is the this is like a really really
terrible chart for you to look at but
I'm going to make you do three more
after this uh if you look at our you
know our contribute contributions to
cncf this was uh last I did this at the
beginning of the month but this is us
this is Google
and that's everyone else contributing to
the cncf
this is a six-month span
there we are
this is a two-year space I changed the I
changed the dots or I don't know why
Kyle what's cncf oh I'm sorry yeah cncf
is the oh gosh
I got into Computing Foundation I got
tied up there for a second uh yeah cncf
thank you and so the cncf is where we
contribute a lot of projects to
kubernetes inside of that Prometheus
inside of it
um but yeah so there's our contributions
like I don't like the downplay how
important open source software is
because we're heavily committed to it we
consistently contribute a lot and like
Google has the resources to do that like
we're very fortunate if that's the case
but that doesn't mean that it's easy to
do and we obviously pay a lot of people
to focus on that so when you start to
think about open source software and you
start really thinking about the
contributions and why that matters I
don't mean to imply that it's not
important that you shouldn't use like
we're really all in an open source and
like I said for me personally that was
like a big reason why I came to Google
after I left red hat
I'm going to walk you through like a
really quick idea of what why this
matters is like when we started looking
at if you're familiar with Prometheus if
you're not I'll briefly explain that
Prometheus is sort of the de facto
standard for kubernetes monitoring uh
specifically around time series metrics
now there could be some debate about
that you can maybe use another tool
that's okay but when we talk about this
I'm going to highlight that you know
this actually came out of Google right
it originally was a project called Borg
mom
and Borgman grew and Grand grew we
ultimately sort of evolved this into a
tool inside of Google called monarch now
Boardman actually was essentially forked
by a couple of Engineers that went to
SoundCloud and you know SoundCloud is
really where Prometheus as it stands
today was invented but it was based
roughly off of board mod and how we
monitored uh workloads inside of Google
I think it was 2012 that they founded
that that project originally at
SoundCloud so so it's been around I mean
it was around for a long time inside of
Google It ultimately evolved because we
hit some of the own capacity you know
some of our own constraints around that
sort of model and you know as we started
looking at this we built out our managed
service for Prometheus just because it
has taken such a strong foothold inside
the space but there's a lot of
challenges to it and so it's not to say
that we don't believe fundamentally in
open source it's that when you really
make the cost considerations and you
have to think about this like there's
more factors than just like I'm gonna
pull software off the shelf and I think
everyone sort of implicitly understands
that but if you don't or if your teams
don't it can be it can weigh on teams a
lot
this is the quote I think this is like
sort of Back To The Grotto speed Libre
it's you know it's free speech not free
beer right and that's maybe like an
easier sort of like less less a verbose
way of saying this I think this is a
really nice summary of like there's
always a cost to something when you
deploy in an Enterprise when you deploy
it in a startup it's always going to
matter and so you have to be tactical
about that you have to really be
considerate about how you're spending
your time in resources I'll come back to
the reason so back to sort of hidden
costs here I don't think this is a
hidden cost but I like to sort of drive
it home for people I think the idea here
is when you think about resource costs
this is the one that people think about
most so if we people don't think about
the human cost people don't think about
the opportunity cost I think people
generally think about this and this is
sort of their Baseline and it's like
well if I run it you know if I run it on
a server underneath my desk where like
it doesn't cost me anything I already
have that server and that's a great way
to start it's a terrible way to scale
so
uh now that I've gone through all the
different ways that we burn money uh I'm
gonna hand it off to Benji to talk a
little bit through how we approach our
software and what we're trying to do for
Google Cloud customers thanks yeah so
I think you can think about Google
Cloud's approach in one key statement
it's really the path of least resistance
or
out of the box
so whether you're a developer building
applications on gcp a business analyst
extracting intelligence to ins to make
informed decisions or a security analyst
who's really managing cyber security
risk or the platform admin who's
managing that platform for a large
Enterprise because you're working on one
maybe multiple clouds Google Cloud
operation has really built the tooling
you need to get your job done so we've
made it compatible with open source just
like Kyle just mentioned whether it's
with Prometheus open Telemetry or even
fluent bent you can bring those assets
those metrics dashboards or alert rules
into Cloud operations every gcp service
has really created or not every a
majority of gcp services have really
provided a day Zero experience for
observability so the moment that you
make that deployment the moment that you
leverage that service you can start
analyzing the system Performance Health
the trends and start troubleshooting
issues immediately
so all that data that's being generated
the metrics the logs that we provide for
you out of the box
is really stored in our planet scale
data platforms these data platforms as
Kyle was mentioning for time series we
call it Monarch but we also support with
bigquery and through that accessibility
you now have a suite of diagnostic tools
that are that are available to you for
you to explore that data you can explore
your metrics your logs you can build
dashboards you can set up alerts so that
you can work with proactive workflows in
the future
ultimately this is the power of Google
Cloud operations
so let's go back to that e-commerce shop
example that we talked a little bit
about earlier
let's ask one more time what is
important for an e-commerce shop
you want to minimize abandonment or Liam
Neeson's giving you a call
no I'm just kidding it'll be a sales rep
um
let's take a look at a self-managed
setup within the popular open source
ecosystem
so here you can see a typical
self-managed open source Prometheus
setup you have the push Gateway with
short-lived jobs you have the
pre-configured alert rules with the
alert manager you have your metrics
being defined with open metrics and the
Prometheus server that's handling all
that and then you have this query
language called prom ql it's uh it's a
it's just another query language that
you have to learn alongside all these
other query languages and grafana is
generally the dashboarding tool that's
preferred on top of Prometheus for data
visualization and for data export
this this is kind of tough because it's
really difficult to scale horizontally
in another prize if you're a startup it
might work for you but the moment you
have multiple engineering teams
development teams that are trying to
spin up their own instance of this good
luck trying to manage all that and
standardize it which brings us to the
next uh challenge it's really difficult
to do Global aggregations right with all
these different instances because now
you have to manage all that ETL all
those different uh ingestion workflows
that are being set up and then the
third challenge is really around
historical data right how do you manage
historical data how do you do those
year-over-year analysis where are you
storing all that information right you
think about Google Cloud again we are
the data platform for a reason
and lastly I think over all this work
that you're putting into it is really an
operational burden it's taking attention
resources capacities away from your
customers into managing your own setup
when in reality you could really have
allocated that to actual features that
deliver value or differentiate your
business
so there is a path
it's the path of least resistance
with Google Cloud operations you can
really have Google manage all of that
for you so Google as I mentioned before
it's open source compatible so you can
bring all those assets into the cloud
while unlocking competitive pricing you
have all that you have Global
aggregation capabilities and most
importantly you also start to unlock a
different value prop it's Google as a
partner
Google's roadmap is focused on AI so as
Google Cloud operations roadmap with AI
starts to evolve AI operations you'll
start to benefit from that that's as I
mentioned as Kyle kind of mentioned
earlier that's compatibility with
Prometheus and open source but you
unlock those data platforms you unlock
vertex AI ml the model Garden all those
capabilities with your data set that'll
allow you to build customized workflow
or even start considering automated
workflows so
ultimately
Google is really committed to building
products that you're going to love so
gaining that partnership is I say it's a
pretty great value problem
but there's one more
Google can scale that's 65 quadrillion
metric points on disk
there's two trillion active time series
inside of Google
supporting Google search and all of our
other products but with Google Cloud as
well now I get it these are really big
numbers and sometimes it's hard to
really fathom what do these numbers
actually mean Kyle can you provide an
example of let's bring this down to
earth yeah I think uh if we take it's
probably the easiest thing to take a
look at is the slide and this is
actually from grafon and so grafana is a
partner of ours this is this is from
them running this in an open source
capacity but this is a 2022 performance
blog post from them focused on
performance for Prometheus stack and so
if you sort of think about this is to
get to a billion active time series
right it's a billion active time series
and memory which is their uh their
aggregation tool if you have multiple
Federated promethia and Prometheus
Promethean I actually don't know if the
Prometheus is is
so uh so but yeah like so the scale here
and then you start to look at this and
like this is this is this is maybe
achievable for one organization when you
need to have multiple when you need to
have if you're especially if you're in a
large organization it just doesn't
there's a sort of a like a diseconomies
of scale here right that's something one
of our co-workers Lee loves to say all
the time but this is achievable for one
it's really not achievable for multiple
and as you start to grow beyond that
like this is just raw compute costs as
opposed to any of the additional
management stuff it takes a massive
amount of compute to get to one billion
time service for your organization
that's again it is achievable and if
you're a really intense engineering
organization like it's doable it's just
like if you want to spend the cost in
there it's ultimately going to be up to
you and how you decide that inside of
your team
I think the important takeaway here is
that you have 1500 replicas of that
instance just to reach one billion
active Time series
or day Zero you can get it out of the
box by Google and be able to scale up
and know that you have up to three two
trillion in scale right it's a
no-brainer
so
let's actually jump into this operation
suite and show you what this day Zero
experience might look like if you've
seen the opening keynote you may have
seen a presentation with the alert
reaction workflow the alert workflow
where you're responding to an alert
you're looking at the metrics maybe
you're navigating with prompt ql there's
a there's a couple AI features to do
natural language exploration and then
you're kind of explaining a log that is
something I would probably call more of
a proactive workflow because you've
already
Telemetry you've set up the alert you
know what you're monitoring what we're
going to show you today is a bit more of
the reactive workflow what happens when
you you didn't set up that alert right
you actually don't know where the
problem is and there's a needle in the
haystack so let's jump into that demo
jump to the next one
more
there we are okay
so I might click and pause through this
uh but but we'll we'll start here so so
this is there's actually a 10 second
delay just when I was recording it but
when we go through this so this is this
is a gke cluster out of the box we
actually deploy one of our jumpstart
Solutions which is uh something else we
can talk about if you're interested but
this deployment automatically handles uh
is there is it going
this is going okay that was just me
taking a while so this is going through
this is automatically going to show you
what's available so this is our
observability and context view as soon
as you deploy a cluster this is
available to you there's no cost for
this all the metrics that we ingest in
this view are automatically provided to
you uh and then you know on the logging
side which we'll talk about a little
later on we only there's only a charge
for logs that you keep so all metrics on
this view are free here we're jumping
into sort of a new view for us which is
an attempt at making this data
meaningful to people who may not have as
much operational experience so if we
click through
could you pause right there Benji
perfect thanks so if you click through
which I just did this is our new view on
troubleshooting playbooks now in this
particular case I had a pod that was
failing it was just you know a python
script that would just exit and then you
know kubernetes would restart it that's
what kubernetes is supposed to do but in
this particular situation we identified
and were able to tell that there was a
crash looping pod and automatically gave
some proactive troubleshooting tips for
you here so as you scroll down you can
go ahead and hit play
uh as we scroll down we can see a little
bit more of what's going on we saw a big
spike in the crashing here and then as
we go down there's logs I just wrote
like an exiting now just to sort of show
you like we're pulling this all in from
the pot we're pulling the metrics in as
well as the logs in the Pod and then
we're going to provide a little bit more
information from the kubernetes cluster
itself now there's nothing here that's
going on that's really crazy you can see
a little bit of log messages we'll also
provide an alert so that if you're
seeing this again and you want to
proactively avoid in the future you can
jump into that alert now that alert will
direct you right back to this Playbook
so if in the future you have an issue
it's fairly easy to sort of get back to
this automatic troubleshooting without
any context or knowledge that's required
from you to set this up we've rolled out
a few of these so far we just introduced
them last month but we have four or five
now they're recently published as well
so let's go back to that cluster we have
a microservice demo it's an it's a uh
it's a demo of an e-commerce shop right
back to the screenshot we saw before
if we take a look at I'm going to click
through to this front-end deployment
and we're going to jump into the
Container logs for this deployment
so here
maybe I just want to get a little bit of
operational data this I want to figure
out without you know having to
instrument my application what Telemetry
is available I just need to figure out
what's going on here I'm going to run a
script I've slightly modified or that
sort of cue can you pause it real quick
thanks Ben so one of the things you'll
notice is when I click through we keep
all the context automatically so as soon
as you click through in a container logs
we know where you're coming from so we
know that you're specifically focused on
this cluster in this region in this
specific container now there's a couple
of different jump points you can sort of
maintain this so if you have this this
application running across multiple
clusters or if it's distributed globally
you can maintain that context for a
global view or for an individual view I
just happen to choose this specific
cluster in this instance of that
front-end application
modify it
and uh the product and just a quick
search in the payload to say serving
product page
now I've already created this but what I
could do from here with this payload is
create and create a metric and you can
sort of see that right here I'll show
you what that looks like in a second if
I've already created it
so I go there
no thanks we click on view metrics
Explorer I'm going to let Benji talk a
little bit about the metrics Explorer
because that's the area he really works
on yeah so as I mentioned to you earlier
all these diagnostic tools are available
available to you out of the box as long
as that data is being generated within
Google Cloud whether you're sending that
data or whether we're providing it for
you so after creating a log base metric
so you're able to monitor that error
you're able to explore that data
directly within the metrics Explorer go
ahead and hit enter the metrics Explorer
allows you to explore that data you can
really just see the insights pretty
quickly now
that's just with exploration what Google
also offers you the ability to query
that without with your own query
languages so as we mentioned there is a
prompt ql compatibility in case you do
prefer writing your own prompt ql
queries because you just have those
Advanced use cases
keep playing yep so if we move over to
the dashboards list which you'll find
pause what you'll find is a list of all
your dashboards but these are not just
dashboards that you generated they're
also the dashboards that we provide for
you out of the box just for using our
services these are the best practice
metrics golden signals CPU memory things
you should be looking at if you're
monitoring one of your applications
let's go ahead and click one of the gke
out of the box dashboards pause oh yep
so this is the GK up key plane this is a
gke out of the box dashboard I'm going
to want to customize it so I'm going to
copy on the top right hand corner
and we'll get to that dashboard in just
a second for the sake of this demo and
with just a single click you're able to
customize a version of one of our
dashboards within one of your own
customized uh views to view those key
kpis and see how that uh that kubernetes
is performing
now this new experience is the dashboard
Builder which was recently redesigned a
few times in about about a month ago we
went General availability with this new
experience if you hit add widget you can
actually see pause here you can actually
see that the dashboard Builder is
expanding across multiple data sources
so you can really bring your metrics
your logs your alerts your incidents in
the future will be bigquery and
eventually SQL analytics to be able to
bring create a single pane of glass with
your dashboards whether you're my
whether you're monitoring the user
experience or the application tier
infrastructure platform or networking
and eventually business insights so
moving forward and hit metric
the metric Explorer opens up we're going
to go ahead and select a metric after
selecting a metric you're going to get
the list of all your metrics that you we
provide for you or that you've brought
into the platform or generated via logs
we'll click the metric that Kyle just
created after clicking that metric
you'll be able to view the data in this
case we're looking at product page
requests hit apply
the data is then returned what apply
and just like that we went from a best
practice Google provided dashboard to a
customized dashboard with your own
analytics and your own insights so you
could monitor your unique application
we're going to talk a little bit about a
product that is just launching now
um recently went into gender
availability February in February which
is logs analytics which is something you
might see in the world with SQL
analytics being able to monitor your
audit logs or you know some folks really
like to use SQL so let's move to that
yeah so when we think about sort of the
views and logging
um going back to originally the thing I
showed you
oh oops can you fix that for me yeah
okay oh yeah
there we go so originally we went back
and we looked at the log view sorry the
the demo the the the the the the work
through on this is a little uh weird
with the with the video but so anyway
when we're looking at prior logs
experience the logs Explorer which we
looked at first to create this metric is
really focused on could deposit is
really focused on sort of exploring and
so when you're in an active
troubleshooting scenario or when you are
dealing with a
you know sort of a a an immediate
response something is going on you got
an alert whatever the logs explorers
want to go to dig into a specific
incident as you saw earlier with
Priyanka in the keynote we have error
reporting you have the ability to sort
of bubble up those errors but we
introduced log analytics because one of
the things we increasingly saw was just
that customers wanted more flexibility
around exploring their data and I would
say like a more Biz Ops or security Ops
focused way and so log analytics is our
sort of introduction to that now it
doesn't replace seam tools tools that
are really focused on like a security
specific use case but it does allow us
some really nice flexibility with this
data so I'll show this query to you in a
second but what you're looking at here
is the payload that we just had with the
same product values and I'm going to run
this through to actually generate a
quick chart on what's going on so you
can see the initial results I have are
just a flat table of everything that's
happened and what we're sorting on is
the number of product requests that I've
had over a period of time that I was
running on it as well as any uh you know
specific codes I've might be reporting
on now you notice like most of these
down here are 200 we had a couple of
nulls up here and I'm not sure why it's
something with the application but we
could see the sort of overall popularity
of products just sort of organized by
the number of requests that we've had
within the time frame on this go ahead
and hit play
if I wanted to I can actually jump into
the charting view here this is currently
in preview it just went live a couple of
weeks ago and I'm just going to organize
this and clean it up to look a little
bit nicer
so we'll change that we'll add a
breakdown component so if I want to add
a
any codes that we may have gotten I
don't think I have 10 codes but you can
sort of see really quickly and go ahead
and pause this is sort of the view of
the breakdown of what we're looking at
where we now have you know how many
products what or sorry what the products
we requested at and sort of what the
overall status of that product request
was so if we're getting a bunch of null
or calls like we need to figure out
what's going on there but but overall
our goal here is to try and provide a
tool that allows you to flexibly slice
and dice your log data in a way that
might be more relevant to your business
as opposed to like an active
troubleshooting scenario
so we're going to wrap up
consider it again like the app the
opportunity cost human cost outage cost
and resource costs these matter
more than others I would argue human
costs might matter than all of them but
you know it just sort of depends on your
you're leaning there and I think when
you think about this finding the right
fit for how your organization
prioritizes work it's not going to be
one size fits all you know Google has a
methodology for this other people have
their own methodologies and that's okay
but it's important to consider the
factors
um if you want to reach out to us I will
say we have um you know we'll be in the
booths the next couple of days you know
that uh uh Booth Duty it gets downstairs
in the devops innovators hive
I'll also recommend a couple of sessions
so we have
um some fairly Hands-On sessions coming
up right so observability for
troubleshooting optimization with open
Telemetry I mentioned we're really
really invested in the open source space
and that really comes to light with open
Telemetry if you're not familiar with
that I would strongly encourage you to
check out open Telemetry and understand
what's going on in that space it's
really important for how we're going to
implement an instrument stuff but it's
also a really great standard in that
space and we think people are going to
you know get a lot of value out of it
um check out our you know do it AI Deep
dive and then the 10 best practices and
uh you know scaling with our partner
over at uh snap so
so we love feedback I guess I should say
please give us feedback and then thank
you
um thank you
foreign